hey everyone in this video we're gonna
be talking about some of the books I've
been reading recently it's been a while
since I've done a video giving an
overall review of what I've reading so
in some cases for these books I'm
actually just gonna point you to other
videos where I've reviewed them in full
which is just as well because there's
quite a lot of three piles before we dig
into the reviews though just two things
to say firstly if you'd like written
kind of in-depth reviews of all of these
books then go to my Goodreads where I've
also got a list of things that I'm
currently reading and I want to even the
future if you want some inspiration and
secondly if you like the sound of any of
the books I talked about in this video
then do go to the description there are
links to the Amazon pages for all the
books I talked about for disclosure
those are affiliate links so if you do
purchase anything from one of those
links then I do get a cut I would
however also like to point out that if
you have a local bookshop near you you
should be absolutely supporting your
local bookshop and trying to find your
books there if you haven't seen them
already I have done whole videos
reviewing in the name of the wind by
Patrick Rothfuss and a brief history of
time by Stephen Hawking
one is better than the other you can
watch the videos and find out links in
the description so first up for this
video the hockey stick and the climate
Wars by Michael Mann there are two kinds
of people who know who Michael Mann is
there are those people who are advocates
for climate change and passionate about
communicating climate change to the
public and then there are people who
don't believe in climate change and that
it's all a scam the reason that both of
these groups of people are familiar with
Michael Mann is that he produced one of
the most iconic figures in the history
of climate science the so called hockey
stick which shows temperatures over the
past thousand years being relatively
constant and then shooting up and the
late 20th century so it looks like the
long shaft and in the upturned blade of
a hockey stick and possibly no other
figure in scientific history has been
met with such ire and with such venom
from people with frankly political and
economic interests Michael Mann wrote
this book because he has been at the
frontline of the climate Wars the
coordinated attack on climate science
and climate scientists by big coal big
fossil fuel lobby groups and by certain
political parties in America that aren't
the Democrats and because he created the
hockey stick figure he arguably has been
the figurehead for these campaigns he's
been the person that has been attacked
over
over and over again it's not just his
research but him as a person and perhaps
this explains why this book is so
meticulously referenced if I hold this
up this much of the book is content as
in you know what you would normally call
the book and this much that's all the
notes and references this thing is
written to be like a watertight legal
document because based on what's
happened to him that's pretty much how
he has to write any bit of science now
so the attacks on the climate change
movement and specifically on the author
form the backbone of the book and that
is a strength and a weakness it's a
strength in that it forms a more
relatable narrative than I think a lot
of other books about climate change
that's this kind of big amorphous
concept this is much more of a personal
story it relates to his place in climate
science history so you can latch onto it
I would say it's a down sight though in
the later stages of the book where it's
basically continued attacks and it's
more of a case of this happened then
this happened then this happened it's
not great storytelling but it is very
good in my opinion science communication
this is a book to read if you are
interested in anthropogenic climate
change and perhaps specifically if
you're interested in where the denier
movement gets its funding from and where
a lot of the more pernicious arguments
for example at the global cooling
argument where they came from
I learned a great deal about in a way
the other side of the argument from this
obviously Michael Mann is very much on
the side of antigenic climate change
being real and being significant but I
learned a lot about how the are the
opponents in that debate the climate
skeptics and deniers think so definitely
worthwhile if you're like me and you
think this is something we should be
talking about and also this would be a
timely read because the figure the
hockey stick figure just turned this
month twenty years old so it's ya know
better time to pick this one up next up
I'm gonna sneak in a section that you
put in basically every one of these book
review videos which is my 40k section
because I've read brothers of the snake
by Dan Abnett I'll keep this on brief
because I know that these books aren't
for everyone but if you are interested
in 40k if you've heard me talk about it
before if you think I'd like to get into
it maybe I have no idea where to start
because there's about a million
different titles I think this is the
perfect introduction it's basically a
neat little in a way it's like a series
of sort of short stories that are put
together into a
but there is an overall art there is an
overall narrative and it's written by
the best author in the black library dan
Abner and specifically the first section
the first one of those short stories is
the best introduction to the the actual
universe of 40k not the warfare side of
things so that does feature obviously
it's about a depth of societies that's
gonna make no sense to most people Simon
but it does give you a really good high
quality look at the background of 4-week
a really great book to start off with if
you were interested in actually getting
into it next I'm going to speed review
two books because I have reviewed these
already but not on my channel I was
invited to do a video on book break
which is Pan McMillan's a youtube
channel about books to talk about my
favorite examples of science writing and
they send me some examples from their
catalogue and there was some perhaps a
few gems in that I've not read before
like I say I'd reviewed these on their
channel so I'm just gonna briefly touch
on them here The Immortal Life of
Henrietta Lacks by Rebecca Skloot is
phenomenal very briefly the book is
about a woman called Henrietta Lacks who
died of cancer in America in the middle
of the 20th century and whose cancerous
cells were taken from her body before
she died without her consent and then
those cells went on to have a very
interesting life in research where they
effectively became immortal they just
kept multiplying and multiplying outside
of her body there are three parts to the
book there is the story of Henrietta
herself there's the story of the
research and researchers who worked with
her cells and most interestingly I think
there's the story of her family and in a
way actually there's another one which
is Rebecca Skloot piecing this whole
thing together and talking to her family
and learning about this tragedy which
happened after she passed away because
oh boy this is there's some
heartbreaking stuff in this book as I
say my full review it is an excellent
example of using techniques normally
found in fictions and fantastic
storytelling techniques in nonfiction
and the book benefits so much from it
honestly one of my favorite books that
I've read in a very long time
if you're interested in the history of
medicine or in ethics or especially if
you are interested in doing practicing
medicine going to university and doing
it essential read and then secondly
completely different but also exquisite
the man who mistook his wife for a hat
by Oliver Sacks
as I say completely different from
more thelife Henrietta Lacks this is a
book of comprised of short stories again
actually it's a bit like brothers of the
snake I think I may be the first person
in history to connect these two books
except in this case the short stories
are patients stories so all of us acts
was a doctor and he specialized in
Neurology and each the each of the
stories in this book are individual
patients with you know details change to
protect their identities and things who
had fascinating from an outsider's
perspective of these fascinating
neurological problems and the titular
character is actually I think the first
chapter the man who mistook his wife for
a hat
it's literally that a man who was
functioning otherwise completely fine
but had no sense of vision wasn't blind
but had no sense of what he was looking
at so when he went to leave this
consultation with Oliver Sacks
he just went over to his wife and tried
to remove her head and put it on his as
a hat the theaters some of the stories
in here that's one of the best ones but
they're incredible incredible things
what to me stood out about the book
though wasn't so much the patients as
the way that all of us acts of Rights is
such a breath of fresh air so refreshing
to have a popular science author who
doesn't write like every other pop
science author but it's clearly well
read as read literature read philosophy
and incorporates a sense of style a
sense of flourish in their prose like
this is just I think the word that I
used in my Goodreads was sumptuous it is
sumptuous to read I'm going to stop
myself now otherwise I'll ramble forever
these two books were reviewed on
footbrake channel I'll leave a link in
the description but both of these are
fantastic fantastic science
communication I should probably address
what may be in elephants in the room to
some viewers which is that in a previous
video I talked about doing a book club
we were all going to read a book
together and that book was homo Deus by
evil Noah Harare and basically these
books that I've been reviewing for panel
McMillan have slightly got in the way of
this I've read a lot of science books
that got in the way
I had the making headway in this not
quite there yet but I don't think there
are any other distractions coming along
the pike that are gonna stop me from
completing this relatively soon somebody
left the entire course go series
including the recently released final
novel an arc
the floor I should put those down before
I reread them so there will be a
standalone video reviewing homo Deus
which is so far promising don't think
it's quite as good as sapiens but there
hasn't gone very speculative yet so
we'll see but yeah that's gonna be
coming in the in the next one price that
then leaves one book to review in this
video the I'll be honest slightly
disappointing hidden life of trees by
Peter for volley been wala Bert Valen
Valen Peter now I say this is
disappointing I think that's actually a
bit harsh I went into this book I had
great things about it a lot of people
recommended it to me and I can see why
people like this I really can this is a
fractured book about trees it basically
is structured into lots and lots of
short chapters if I show you the
contents page that's the first lot of
chapters you're going to change white
balance so what the book is comprised of
these pithy little chapters that are
based on a particular theme for example
like hibernation the idea of trees
getting into hibernation or the idea of
trees specializing or trees being in
love lots of things which are really
interesting I don't like the way that
they were told I kind of have to ask
myself what do I actually look for in a
nonfiction book are they were
interesting things in this book
absolutely yes are there things which
I'd never even considered before it's
like changing the way that I'm looking
about the world yeah definitely was it
told in an engaging way
not really perhaps it's suffering by
comparison to the mining mistook his
wife for a house I think in a way this
is souring a lot of other books that I'm
reading subsequently because this shows
how beautifully you can write in
nonfiction write about science and you
know that in a way they're quite similar
again there's three books in this video
which quite similar in a way they're
quite similar in that they're both
formed as short chapters these are case
histories these are sort of short
chapters based around ideas these feel
complete and contain musings and after
they are finished with a chapter you
kind of want to put the book down
think about it for a bit with this one I
was just impatient to move on to the
next chapter because I felt like the
momentum was stalling it was like being
on one of those tube trains well you're
just constantly kind of being loved
backwards and forwards you go through
there was no sense of flow to this book
every time I felt like I was kind of
getting into it with the chapter would
stop and it would move on to something
else I I want to like it I really do
want to like it the stuff in it is
interesting but I it's frustrating to
read the best analogy that I can think
of for this book is it's like going to a
pub and there's an old guy sat at a
table and he's had a really interesting
life and he'll tell you a story for a
couple of minutes then you know you'll
wander off and do something else and
then you might prod him again in a few
minutes time and I'll tell you another
story those stories are interesting but
just when they get good he kind of
wanders off and you know it's it's all
fragmented it's it's all fractured into
moments rather than a coherent story yes
I know this is not fiction it's not a
story but just because something's
nonfiction that doesn't mean you can't
have good storytelling oh this is gonna
be another name of the wind situation
people aren't gonna like this okay I'm
walking away from that review that's
gonna is gonna piss off a lot of people
so like I say I'm currently reading homo
Deus and chugging through that I also
have this pile of books which have been
including some presents of Christmas
feeling some the astronomy handbook is a
reread the planets one is a reread some
of these I've been sent by publishers
this one actually made me borrow your
language about about etymology I love
etymology I'm a few chapters into this
actually I've been picking at it that's
really interesting but yeah this is
getting a bit ridiculous seeing as I'm
also rereading Dawn's ghosts I've got
way too many books on the guy at the
moment no so I'm gonna say I'm not gonna
say it I'm not gonna ask you for
recommendations because I am Alive for
book recommendations thank you very much
if you however have been reading
anything interesting recent they do give
a review down in the comments or if
you've read any of the books that I've
read and you'd like to review them and
especially if you disagree with me do
put that down in the comments and the
conversation on these book videos is
always really enjoyable to me certainly
a lot more enjoyable than the
conversations on the climate change
videos that's all for now thank you very
much for watching if you like the sound
and only the books do check out the
links in the description if you enjoyed
the video that
do pop it a like or subscribe if you're
not already and thank you very much for
watching I'll see in the next one